yes hello and welcome
to this video i wasn't quite sure if i'm
on
but i think i am okay now
this is a funny move order not a funny
one it's a good move order for white
and i try to maximize the dirty harry's
out of this
and i'm going to play a move that is not
really great but
i'm hoping for d4
[Laughter]
hoping for d4 yeah i get it okay
i mean d4 is certainly not a mistake but
um you can certainly argue that h5
is a bit less pointed after bishop b5 or
bishop c4
now we got a dirty hairy problem
this is probably international master
peter lodge right
i've played plimsoll on the
icc back in the day
oh wait why is that not
on wait
now we got this yeah this is strange
and now the time very very weird
somehow that was not in the layout i had
this problem before
this is three plus two by the way i mean
he can take a bit of
time there with white
quite clearly i'm a little bit ahead on
the theoretical knowledge side here
nobody knows anything about this with
white and if you are
the author of the one and only dirty
harry opening repertoire
and it's really the one and only
you should be the better prepared player
okay now something like
g3 or bishop e2 is reasonable
i've met queen d2 very often which runs
right into a bishop h6
okay so f4 g3 here
um this is my
my prep
it's a bit odd but this is the way to go
the way this is played is the queen has
to stay on d1
so that he cannot castle queenside so
easily
and i have moves like this useful moves
i'll get the queen to
c5 now i have useful moves
and this position here is in my mind
completely playable and quite unclear
it's really tough to say what's going on
it has a clear similarity to
the rouser variation but i have not
played d6
which is a pretty
substantial difference so ff5
doesn't really
constitute a danger i think okay this
one
yeah i wanted to go f5 here anyway is
that a problem
i thought that this would be quite
reasonable here controlling e4
and now i get b5 bishop b7 in
h3 and g4 that's an idea for white
me unpaint um yeah just to
try to get rid of both pawns on h5 and
f5 so that e4 becomes
available for knight that could be an
idea
i'm not really sure what else white can
do
okay he's trying to
say that h5 is a weakness
okay it should be seven
queen to d3 probably i can also play
at some point the move d6
to trying to break
open
the center
i think i'm doing it
the bishop should be really good on f6
shortly
i have to pay attention to not
play too fast i played a
tournament yesterday in arena tournament
which was
which was played in five minutes but i
berserked our games
and it was much
it was essentially a two and a half
minutes tournament
okay i'm trying to get the king to g7
so king g7 is he threatening something i
don't
see it
we need two coming i can make i can just
play the end game which is not
a problem and i take everything on the
form
i wonder is there something
very dangerous happening if i
play king g7
king g7 i don't know c3
knight c6 says rook b6 i don't think so
i can take on d4 and be okay but
it's a bit lame
this one
should be okay huh
queen d6 bishop b7
what is the thing here bishop bishop b7
right
i know it can take knight a5
i have queen before though okay
should make sure that i'm not falling
asleep at the wheelie i mean i
have much more time but
at some point it will it will go
down the time
it's kind of helpful
to speed up
not threatening much now i can play
queen e4 maybe
this is a good move takes takes i'm
threatening e3
um
okay
to play rookie
i look before i can he can just take
okay
so let's cover ah
you can go there that's that's so stupid
overlooking this move
it's really annoying now i'm in trouble
after
being much better the whole game
yeah i'm not sure much better but it was
clearly white struggling
knight f6
okay we've got 25 seconds again
so grab this
check and now the h
pawn it's the
it's far away from everything else so
go baby
and knight c5 was a very strange move
how does the rook come back now
at least rook c5 c1 was an option
now i completely completely um
screwed this up at the end yeah i didn't
really make much of my really nice
position i think when we um
go here i'm completely fine
and i think a couple of moves later my
position was certainly
preferable when we were
here
let's say some somewhere here i think
okay queen d6 it seems was a concretely
good move but
ah sure of course yeah i did not see
that i saw that i can play here but
in this particular moment i cannot go to
b4
so then queen d6 was very good but i was
thinking like here i should be fine
right
yeah yeah because just because here we
have the pure advantage of that
long-range bishop against the knight
and he lost even this this time when the
position looked really fine
between a4 is very strong for b4
yeah okay
a b4
oh that's nice that's a nice idea that's
a nice idea he cannot
play a4 because of the capture
yeah and now all of a sudden i'm winning
the house
and that means he has no good move
against before yeah
taking is pretty awful as well
got this coming and yeah that's awful
okay and queen e4 was a was a bad idea
it seems you can simply take
okay
and yeah i think i lost
i just lost time
okay that is a very
drastic measure the engine suggestions
here
i mean i win a ton of pawns but
it looks i would really assume that
white must be a lot better here with the
beep with the a pawn
but maybe i'm fast enough
the 0 0 0 is kind of
telling this
this a4
and really i'm fast enough here with the
f pawn okay
it is fast yeah that's true
okay okay that is reasonable i played
rook c4 and now i'm definitely in
trouble
because i'm really slow but he somehow
managed to lose more time
[Music]
this yeah and there was a blunder here
this here and now i i just blunt it king
h7 is a huge mistake
i should play whatever rook h3h it's got
knight f6 here
but okay i don't have to take i can play
king here
[Music]
or yeah king h6 at least
but then this one
wow it's a tough one i can check
and play this
and now at the end of the day
i can get this it's a purely tactical
ending
but the white king is helping yeah it's
winning for white it seems
rookie eight was not a good idea
and here i'm already uh completely
winning
the pawns are a little bit faster and
i also have them better better minor
piece
yeah knight c5 was not
helping but it's already uh beyond
saving
i have i can push the h pawn and i have
rook a1 to force it through
yeah not the best game ever really
thanks for watching